boa noite a todos
eu costumo me apresentar como um
desertor como um dissidente num momento
em que a vida parecia que tinha deixar
todas as cartas sobre a mesa eu resolvi
usar a minha liberdade humana para dizer
não não é isso que eu quero vou pra
outro caminho e aos 42 anos de idade eu
me reinventei mais uma vez é um pouco
essa história que eu queria contar pra
vocês eu nasci num bairro na periferia
da cidade de são paulo chamado bairro do
limão um bairro de classe média baixa
bastante baixa
como todos meus amigos em virtude além
do estrato social em que eu tinha
nascido
sempre deixei muito claro que eu deveria
fazer na vida
eu tinha dois grandes objetivos o
primeiro era sobreviver
pura e simplesmente sobreviver e o
segundo era vencer não importa muito o
que significa se essa idéia de vencer
uma parte grande dos meus amigos
infelizmente não seguiu a regra não
sobreviverão eu tive muitos amigos
mortos pelo tráfico mortos pela polícia
mortos por ambos ao mesmo tempo no
ambiente em que eu nasci o simples fato
de sobreviver já era uma vitória já era
uma forma de vencer
e nesse ambiente então eu comecei a
trabalhar aos 14 anos de idade já
trabalhava como office-boy tentava
ganhar livro dinheirinho e continue ali
e meus pais sempre fizeram muita questão
da questão educacional sempre preciso
melhoraram muito com a questão
educacional estudei em escolas públicas
a vida inteira e continuei então
trabalhando e estudando simultaneamente
até conseguir
depois você tem que me formar em
jornalismo
durante mais de dez anos eu atuei nas
redações de jornalismo conseguir uma
carreira de jornalista que já não é
muito fácil também é uma profissão
bastante concorrida eu trabalhei
é em lugares nos quais aprendi muito nos
gastos lugares nos quais realmente
conseguir realizar ali na profissão de
jornalista é durante esse período da
vida como jornalista eu descobri uma
outra vocação que era a vida acadêmica e
me lembra o primeiro dia que entrei numa
sala de aula
já atuando como jornalista foi trabalhar
num curso de jornalismo e me encantei
totalmente pela educação e decidi que
era aquilo que eu queria fazer
já dei a minha primeira virada aí
abandonei jornalismo e fui pra vida
acadêmica
fiz mestrado que duas pós graduações
lato sensu antes
depois fiz mestrado doutorado pós
doutorado acabei me tornando o professor
doutor em uma das instituições mais
respeitadas do país na área de
comunicação que é a faculdade cásper
líbero de são paulo
ali eu cheguei ao ponto máximo de uma
carreira acadêmica que é ser um
professor doutor dentro de um programa
de pós-graduação é eu ganhava um ano o
que meu pai e não ganhava em 10.000
solar é um salário bastante alto e eu
tinha uma vida que deus aos meus amigos
e viajava muito porque a rigor é só
porque só precisava estar na faculdade
três dias por semana é é uma carga
horária relativamente baixa
apesar de tudo isso onde eu podia olhar
para trás e pensar
deu certo eu não apenas sobrevive eu
acho que de alguma forma eu venci de
alguma forma eu cheguei no ponto em que
é a minha história podia ser muito bem
uma história dessas de um grande sucesso
que o capitalismo promove uma história
de ascensão social do menino pobre que
com esforço consegue uma profissão ela
poderia ser mais uma dessas histórias
linhas mas sim a um pequeno probleminha
tinha uma sombra tinha alguma coisa que
o tempo todo me dizia
será que é só isso será que acabou será
que agora é como dizia raul seixas fica
sentado no trono de um apartamento com a
boca escancarada cheia de dentes
esperando a morte chegar é isso
cheguei lá ponto essa para sobreviver
pra vencer da forma como foi o caso
fazer a gente tem que engolir muitos
sapos tem que fazer muita coisa que não
acredita tem que fazer muita coisa que
não quer tem que fazer muita coisa que
simplesmente não se deseja e toda vez
que eu fazer uma coisa dessas que
engolir um sapo e me perguntava por que
por que que eu estou fazendo isso
qual é a razão de fazer isso porque eu
vou gastar os melhores anos da minha
vida atrás de dinheiro atrás de
conseguir essa idéia do vencer atrás
pura e simplesmente de me realizar
profissionalmente e eu comecei a ganhar
algum dinheiro e paradoxalmente quanto
mais dinheiro ganhava mais assombra
aumentava mas eu sentia que aquilo que
eu estava fazendo não fazia sentido
ou melhor fazia sentido mas que havia um
outro sentido que havia alguma outra
coisa que era mais importante pra mim
procurar mais importante pra mim decidir
realizar no final de nove horas de
trabalho todos os dias eu chegava em
casa já morava sozinho nessa época me
sentava no sofá e perguntava tá
o que foi que eu fiz o que foi que
efetivamente eu realizei
é pra isso eu tô indo lá para ganhar um
dinheirinho e comprar alguma coisa que
certamente eu não preciso que certamente
eu nunca pensei em ter em que eu só
conto para simplesmente uma auto
complacência já que eu trabalhei tanto
então eu mereço contra isso já que eu
trabalhei tanto eu mereço comer nesse
restaurante já que eu trabalhei tanto
porque trabalham tanto a pergunta não
fazia muito sentido e eu eu perguntava
uma pergunta eu faço a vocês no íntimo
de vocês têm de responder se amanhã
vocês ganharem na mega sena
trinta milhões de reais quantos de vocês
continuariam fazendo o trabalho que
fazem
se você respondeu como a maior das
pessoas tá louco eu iria viajar eu iria
passear eu iria curtir a vida então
lamento mas o que você faz você faz pelo
dinheiro e não pelo valor daquilo que
você faz
porque se eu perguntar pra você se você
ganha 30 milhões de reais você larga seu
filho no orfanato
mas ela não quer mais a criança não
agora tem outro milionário eu vou largar
esse título aqui e vou curtir a vida
a maior parte vocês já que não porque o
filho é importante não é a grana que
você tem aquilo que é realmente
importante não se mede em dinheiro não
se mede na grana e eu vivia trabalhando
até ao que eu gostava que eu era
vocacionado mas todo o ambiente
institucional toda a burocracia toda a
falta de perspectiva pessoal que estava
fazendo pairava em mim como uma sombra
de maneira que eu me sentia sempre
trabalhando para comprar bugigangas que
eu não precisava
quando eu vinha de uma origem muito
modesta é o dinheiro toca o dinheiro
chega uma hora que ele você começa a
afundar no dinheiro e me sentia
literalmente afundando dinheiro aqui uma
pausa uma confidência minha mãe
cozinhava muito mal
um dos grandes traumas da minha infância
era uma péssima cozinha
tanto eu quanto meu irmão assim que
saímos de casa e começamos a trabalhar
fora engordamos loucamente
eu gastava uma boa parte do dinheiro
comendo comendo coisas maravilhosas e
implementando parta de trufa negra eu
tinha minha própria máquina de café
expresso em casa que é uma coisa
maravilhosa e gastava assim fábulas
comprando cafezinhos expressos
diferenciados para tomar depois das
recessões fazer os banqueiros aprendi a
cozinhar codornas codornas assadas da
onde eu vinha aquilo era o que eu
precisava viver mas a cada dia a cada
codorna a cada café zinho ele imaginava
é isso então trabalho que nem um cavalo
faz um monte de coisa que eu não sei
qual é a utilidade para vir aqui tomar
cafezinho alguma coisa estava errada à
sombra e aumentando o que me incomodava
era uma sensação muito simples eu estava
perdendo a vida pra ganhar a vida
a estação hidrológica que a maior parte
das pessoas tem um dado momento de que
gasta a vida inteira pra ganhar a vida
que não quer a vida que não procurou a
vida que não desejou trabalhar comprar
trabalhar comprar trabalhar com pra
trabalhar com pra trabalhar comprar
coisas que você não precisa pagar da
pessoa que você não se importa não é
verdade nós mas temos uma compulsão de
comprar coisas que não precisamos como
essas coisas fossem nos preencher e
essas coisas
evidentemente nunca nos preenche
então eu comecei a montar um plano
eu vou usar esse meu dinheiro não para
comprar coisas mas para comprar uma
única coisa uma carta de alforria eu
quero sair desse sistema
eu vou usar o dinheiro para sair do
sistema econômico eu vou usar
paradoxalmente o recurso para não
precisar do recurso eu vou investir numa
forma de me transformar cada vez mais em
autonomia diante da possibilidade
econômica e passei então a tentar
imaginar como é que eu faria isso como é
que eu poderia usar o dinheiro para não
precisar de dinheiro um único fim justo
que eu via para meu dinheiro era chegar
o dia em que eu não precisasse do
dinheiro
comecei então a montar um plano na minha
cabeça de como fazer isso
na época eu não sabia mas isso tem um
nome
isso se chama de crescimento o que eu
estava tentando fazer é o que alguns
economistas tentam aplicar numa escala
maior
a economia de alguns países ea economia
global principalmente num momento de
crise ecológica que é a idéia de você
diminuir o pib pra aumentar a satisfação
diminuir o dinheiro para aumentar o
prazer tirar da esfera econômica o maior
número possível de atitudes humanas
uma coisa interessante pessoal de
crescimento fala muito faz muito sentido
se por algum motivo específico sei lá
por alguma razão no um 2016 no brasil
houver mais acidentes automobilísticos
do que em geral o número
desde o motor bispos quadruplicou o pib
aumenta mais pessoas tiveram que
consertar seu carro mais pessoas
trocaram o carro mas se pagou em oficina
mas se comprou peça mais hospitais
ficaram lotados mas ataduras foram
vendidas mais cirurgias foram feitas
médicos contratados mais enfermeiros
contratados e parece que houve uma
prosperidade advinda de acidente de
trânsito
as pessoas estão morrendo e o pib
aumenta não há uma relação entre o que
você ganha de dinheiro ea fascinação que
você tem e aquilo que você pode tirar da
vida como prazer e aquilo que você
realiza na sua vida o que eu queria
então era retirar o maior número
possível de atitudes minhas cotidianas e
liberar o maior tempo possível e já há
alguns anos eu venho trabalhando nessa
idéia de liberar o maior tempo possível
da esfera econômica e eu quero tirar a
minha vida da economia
o primeiro passo foi a simplicidade
voluntária abrir mão das bugigangas
a vida é melhor sem uma máquina de café
expresso
a vida é muito melhor sem comer trufas
porque a riqueza não está naquilo que se
tem mas aquilo que você não precisa eu
adorava passear no shopping com amigos e
onde há coisas em que eu não quero olha
aquela blusa aquela coisa que eu não
quero aquela blusa que eu não preciso
aquela calça que não me faz a menor
diferença e adquirir o hábito de medir o
preço de tudo em horas de vida excelente
hábito e olha uma causa mas sim eu tenho
que trabalhar 14 horas acontece a calça
eu prefiro 14 horas livres do que ter
essa calça
tudo que eu olhava eu precise ficava o
tempo vivido e pouca coisa vale a pena
quando você perde fica em tempo devido
depois disso opa
eu fui me dando conta também que para
sair da economia eu precisava aumentar
as minhas habilidades
eu precisava aumentar a minha autonomia
eu precisava ser capaz de produzir
coisas que eram úteis para mim
ao invés de comprar eu poderia ganhar
cada vez menos na condição que eu
fizesse cada vez mais transformar se no
trabalho numa atividade feita
exclusivamente para troca numa atividade
que pudesse realizar a minha própria a
minha própria necessidade eu passei
então a usar esse dinheiro para comprar
algumas coisas muito específicas
ferramentas habilidades e conhecimento
discurso de tudo que você possa imaginar
o discurso de pedreiro um discurso de
pintor diz curso de eletricista fez
curso de mecânica de carro eu sei operar
motosserra eo trator
eu sei que consertar um trator eu sei
fazer uma horta eu fui a a aec criando
mecanismos para desenvolver a minha
autonomia
houve um passo fundamental nos falou que
aqui algumas vezes à mendicidade hoje
não é possível ter uma relação autônoma
fora do mercado dentro da cidade
principalmente dentro de uma grande
cidade
as cidades elas são sim espaço de
convivência espaço da civilização
mas elas também surgem a partir do
mercado
a cidade é o espaço da é ter o nome a a
cidade o espaço da troca
se eu quisesse ter uma relação de
autonomia e retirar me da economia e
fugir da economia eu precisava do campo
eu precisava buscar o campo e foi o que
eu fiz é conseguir comprar uma pequena
terrinha
só que tinha um problema
a maior parte do dinheiro gastava com
comida e com sociabilidade comida eu
resolveria no campo social habilidade e
ocorreria o sério risco de ficar isolado
de morar em uma propriedade rural sem
vizinhos sem nenhum tipo de vida social
que ela que eu tinha na cidade
eu não eu não queria ficar sozinho
evidentemente e aí eu descobri que eu
não estava sozinho
eu descobri que há uma subcultura que é
um conjunto grande de pessoas que estão
indo vivenciar essas
se no campo e que hoje é subcultura
chamada de os novos rurais os neo rurais
é um bando de gente das mais variadas
idades que têm em comum uma decepção com
o espaço urbano uma tentativa de viver
uma vida com maior autonomia e que estão
buscando em uma vida rural a
possibilidade de ter uma liberdade que
não é possível na cidade
essas pessoas a maior parte delas tem
curso superior têm um alto grau de
conhecimento é viveu muito universo das
artes os espetáculos da música e da
gastronomia não são pessoas que estão no
lar pra atender àquele a que tipo do
jeca tatu aquele que adquire isolado no
meio do grotão são pessoas que estão
revigorando a vida no campo trazendo o
vocabulário novo estão falando de
permacultura então falando de água
floresta então falando de bioconstrução
de arquitetura intuitiva de agroecologia
estão trazendo tecnologias diferenciadas
e apropriadas para a vida do campo estão
indo em grande número em estão realmente
provocando uma nova cultura no campo
hoje então eu consegui eu encontrei a
minha tribo que é essa tribo dos novos
murais conseguir comprar minha terrinha
lá na cidade de piracaia na cidade de de
25 mil habitantes que fica perto de
atibaia na grande são paulo se chama
sítio pau d'água e é um local onde nós
tentamos vivenciar em realizar projetos
nessas áreas de agroecologia de
bioconstrução de construção sustentável
enfim em que os novos rurais da região
são muito atraídos por aquela região
encontram um espaço para fazer
experimentações para testar novas
convivências neste momento está sendo
construído na propriedade já não é mais
minha eu sou administrador do kilamba
ela é meio comunitária coletiva
estamos construindo um prédio agora que
o carinhosamente estou chamando de o
cortiço porque é uma residência
multifamiliar e vou morar lá com mais
duas famílias no esquema que o exterior
eles chamam meio prudentemente de corral
zin
nós vamos dividir uma casa o sítio é um
sítio coletivo é um sítio para que
várias pessoas possam viver as suas
experiências
para finalizar é um pouco dessa história
do professor doutor edilson caso de luto
que de repente aos 42 anos de idade
conseguiu se reinventar como o discurso
lá eu sou disso o discurso do pau d'água
aquele da porteirinha ver meia sempre
que passa tem um cheirinho de café
sempre que passa tem alguém proseando na
varanda sempre toda noite tem alguém
sentado numa rede tomando uma caixa
assim e tocando viola e vocês são
bem-vindos também quer aparecer por lá a
próxima aguarda os ligado